[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
i am
uh
ben janka it's been too
long my dude you are telling me
where does the time go uh but you know
what
i'm glad that we're back and we're back
today
of all the times to be back with a
wonderful exciting
live stream for all of you people the
playstation the playstation 5. we have
it we're gonna stream it for you
as i'm sure you've all seen we have uh
our reviews of uh both the playstation 5
along with spider-man
astros a bunch of other stuff going up
today
and throughout the weekend uh all for
you guys so please
go check that stuff out if you haven't
uh but for now
let's play some astros yeah i actually
haven't seen a lot of this game so i'm
gonna be kind of like
i like this game learning things this
game is really cute
uh i unfortunately have to delete my old
save but it's okay
i've already platinum the game so it's
fine
there you go um so i'm sure people in
the chat will keep asking but just to
say
up front no we're not allowed to show
the ui
um if you want to see that you can go
see that in the review and
stuff like that but uh there are still
some things about the ui that are
um like a work in progress and so um
we're we've been asked to not show it on
a live stream
environment right now um
and okay yeah so so this is astr's
playroom it's basically
a free game that you get uh with your
playstation 5.
it's it's kind of pitched as like a tech
demo to show off the the new dual sense
uh but it's actually a really fun little
platformer that i
quite enjoyed um it's also like
just full of like playstation references
and and little like gimmicks um
look at that look at that controller
being built
i love to build a controller to start my
my day off
the astro like series has always been
kind of kind of interesting
look at these adaptive triggers uh i
like the
the jets going off right now i will say
the one thing about um this that what
might not
tran that will definitely not translate
on the stream is
because this game the things that make
this game really cool is um
specific to like the controller like the
adaptive triggers
and the haptic feedback all these little
astros
shake them up oh this unless you shake
them up
yep that it's the most important bit it
reminds me of the
the rabbids uh games on the the wii
to the microphone i don't know if i'm
blowing into
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say anything
uh but yeah like i don't know it's one
of those things where maybe you'll
appreciate how cute the game is but you
won't appreciate how
um cool some of the controller features
are
on a stream it's one of those things
that you really do have to like actually
play yourself
to appreciate um it's kind of how i feel
about the controller in general i mean i
think that that's sort of a common
sentiment i've been hearing among a lot
of people who've played this controller
is like
wow the uh adaptive triggers are really
cool
and i hope that other developers
actually take advantage of it and
and it doesn't become it doesn't go the
way of the six axis
or you know the many other uh abandoned
playstation features over the years it's
definitely good when they can find a way
to kind of
maximize the the potential for that and
i see anthony ferlin in the chat asking
if we're going to read the chat yeah
i'm going to be trying to read you guys
messages as well as i can
uh but also this is kind of like uh
across the we're also just kind of
hanging out showing some stuff off
but yeah i need to answer as many
questions as i am able to answer
um i can also answer questions about the
ps5 in general i can't
like i said i can't show off the ui but
if you have any questions about things
relating to the playstation i can't
answer i i did help
uh the lovely matt padgett cut the video
review
um so i'm very intimately familiar with
the workings the ps5 at this point
[Music]
and have my own thoughts on it
also the music in this game bops uh yeah
i was gonna stay
these are some some real bangers um
so like something that you guys won't be
able to tell at all but like when i am
walking the controller like vibrates
every little every little like
tink he makes every little like foot
foot tap
oh there's a little vibration and the
controller like makes a sound
it's it it's really cool i i like it
quite a bit
uh also because i i i've got to do it i
see our boy bob jones in the twitch chat
asking what about twitch chat also
reading twitch chat
also reading twitch chat excellent got
all these chats up
i can't hold all these chats okay so
we're going to
let's start let's start a level up here
go to memory meadow
so each level is themed um
the the premise here is you're like
inside a playstation 5 and so you're
going like here i'm i'm now i'm in the
memory
of the playstation 5.
and look all these little uh flowers
have little playstation symbols on them
and i like that a lot
uh there are a ton of references so
let's see if we can figure them out so
here's uh
i think this is flower
oh yeah because the the petals flying
around yeah yeah so anytime you see like
a guy with a camera
that means they're like shooting a
a little reference to to playstation
history
i i'm i'm kind of getting more and more
soul because i thought it was just kind
of like a
silly platformer thing but the fact that
it's it comes free with the ps5
yeah uh and it's kind of just
like a collection of cool things if
you're somebody who's like a huge fan of
playstation
you're gonna like geek out over this i
mean look like look it's the playstation
one
chord oh oh
look at that look at that dang
this is little guy over there hey guy
what's up
this has turned from like a thing where
i i thought that i wasn't really gonna
like do much with it right away to i i'm
probably gonna play this first
it it's honestly what it's very fun
like i happily 100 of it but two i do
think it is actually a very good
showcase of the controller
um and showing off that stuff oh look at
the wind
yeah get that little wind
uh so people who are asking uh why why
this one is it's it's the package
like in packed in game but we're also
going to be playing
uh that we are
currently allowed to play so yeah we're
allowed to play
astro and then um uh
the people at capcom are letting us do a
little bit of devil may cry as well
um what's this one here uh also ape
escape
oh that's definitely ape escape oh it's
ape escape
that's good my favorite part of metal
gear solid three side
modes
uh but there are a lot of people asking
uh for demon souls remaster stuff
believe me as soon as we're able to do
stuff with that i guarantee you're gonna
see a bunch of it
yeah we'll we'll we'll be there once
we're allowed to
uh for sure uh i think this is
how i'm honestly not sure oh that's uh
that's your daniel fortescue that's uh
medieval
oh it's medieval okay so he's got a
little skulls there
okay makes sense
uh raphael wants to know
uh what how how's the frame rate been
have you noticed like any any dips or
anything and anything like that no
the frame rate has been smooth on
uh every game i've i've been playing so
far um
that's that's a ps5 game um obviously
like playing ps4 games
uh backwards compatible it's all
dependent on how those games were but
like astra has been smooth
um spider-man was smooth uh
dove may cry has been smooth so yeah you
unlock these little artifacts and
they're
uh little playstation accessories
look at that that's that old original
playstation one controller without the
the dual shockness to it
and like when i hit the button oh it
actually does the buttons
yeah that's that's real neat though yeah
these are like really really well done
um 3d models and they have them for
like everything like it they they get
real
they get real obscure uh do they have
the memory card that you can record like
voice lines into
uh so i had one of those and i
yes yes yes yes i think they for real
i think they did oh it was like it kind
of had it kind of looked like a
tamagotchi
yeah yeah they have that oh geez
uh some people asking how long the game
is
uh took me
i want to say it'll take you around like
three to four hours uh
maybe a little bit trying to do
everything no no no it's for a free game
you're getting it's it's pretty good
oh that's tearaway that classic
uh necessarily
vitamins means life
um
uh senor tiger wants to know what
benefits do you feel with the gameplay
using that new controller or what
what benefits much is that sam porter
bridges what is this that is sam porter
bridges
uh but yeah what what what benefits do
you feel kind of using the the newer
controller versus like the old ones like
things that you
you think you might be able to kind of
get out of it
uh because starters the the just the
general like
uh feed oh i wasn't paying attention the
general epic feedback i think just feels
really good
i think it's like you know i think
rumble has been
um as a tech hasn't really evolved that
much
in the in the last couple console
generations this feels like a
significant advancement where
it can produce more um
subtle rumble when it needs to and then
more louder rumble like it's not like a
binary just like
the gear spins and rumble happens um
because
the controller actually has little
speakers in it
that are that's how it's doing rumble
it's gonna say because the rumble now
isn't just in like the the parts where
your hand
is at it's also like in the whole like
mainframe of the controller
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of wild yeah so
like i think that stuff is like really
really cool
and then um the the haptic triggers i
think are rad
uh there's all sorts of like cool
applications for that where
so here what's um
apparently there's some stream stuff
going on possibly
uh what do you mean uh some where we're
dropping frames possibly it's not the
game
let me check let me check um i am
getting a little bit of drop frames
uh let's see
shall i uh lower the let me lower the
bitrate a little bit
twitch is apparently good but it might
be a youtube thing maybe
maybe youtube's just busted okay guys
hold on for like half a second
i'm gonna stop and start it really
really quick uh hold on for one we
should be back up in a sec
uh
let me know what let me know when we're
back up on everything else
stream looks fine we're back on twitch
cool okay all right guys hopefully that
is good let me know if
uh we're continuing to get any drops
um let's just keep going
yeah let's let's continue our adventure
uh i saw before all the the stream stuff
happened there were a few people
asking about battery life for the
controller it's
i haven't done like an exact measurement
but it's it's better than the dualshock
4 which let me tell you i was getting
super frustrated with the battery life
of the dualshock 4.
um it felt like it ran out so quickly
it's it's way better
than this then umbrella
heavy rain this is it
uh i don't think that's actually the
case but i just got excited
i think that's last guardian over there
oh yeah
that not bird dog bird dog
uh also questions uh that's a good
reminder uh
how is the controller speaker compared
to the one on the dualshock 4
is it is it higher quality
maybe i'd say it's comparable it's it's
definitely as comparable
probably it's probably a little bit
better but i i
i would have to do like a side-by-side
comparison um
speaking of heavy rain oh dang
just like that oh he's not actually
can't be dead
he's the origami napper
uh still lagging if you guys are still
having some issues with lag maybe try
lowering the the resolution if you can
yeah i just checked we're not getting
dropped frames anymore so
for now it's not on our end
yeah but i do appreciate any updates if
you guys feel like we are dropping
frames
uh that's another question too going off
of the the speaker question
uh is the mic comparable like have you
guys gotten a chance to mess with that
much or
i feel like you'd have to like in
specific games or you know
i haven't tested party chat yet i i
should test that it's weird that it has
a built-in microphone like there's a
part of me that's like
i don't like the idea that just suddenly
i could be on mic
and i don't know uh yeah
uh but i'm sure they probably have
nothing for that i i assume they do
um but i i haven't actually tried the
mic yet oh
dang it i got spiked
heavens are the best of us
uh will fortnite have 120 fps
compatibility i don't know what
fortnite's gonna have
that's a good question i hope it has a
lot of frames though
i mean i feel like that game would be
able to run that right
yeah it's got an art style that lends
itself to that for sure
amazon still isn't giving me an
estimated delivery date on my ps5
i i actually just got mine for my my
xbox
and unfortunately it's it i don't know
how i lucked out and actually got my
xbox coming on launch day but
seems to seems to work
i need to double check that i think last
i heard
walmart said mine was going to arrive a
day or two later
look at that look at these clouds look
at these playstations
do you know if the game if if astrobot's
running at 120 or if it's running at 60
it's running at 60. it's not doing well
bye oh i get that guy too
uh could we play sack boy's big
adventure i wish i'm actually really
excited to play that
i'm actually excited to play it too at
first i was like i don't know
and then i like was thinking about how
much i like i loved the original olympic
planet
and then i played this and i was like
you know what actually i could really go
for a wholesome platformer
what in the name of negoshi monkey balls
is this
uh so i am controlling it using the
touchpad
right now i want i want negotia to make
a new uh monkey ball game
and i want him to put kiryu in the
monkey ball
i didn't look if there was a yakuza
reference oh man
i i hope i feel like yakuz is at the
point where it's for everyone now
it's it's all really yes it's wild to
think of the year 2020
uh the new yakuza would be
a premier xbox launch game
yeah right not ps5 that's that's bizarre
to me
when are we starting dmc five what do we
know what our our
our time breakdown is for this how much
time we're spending on each
uh we don't i'm i'm more than happy to
do it switch at any time like i don't
well
i'm definitely not going to show too
much of this game because i obviously
want people to experience it for
themselves
um yeah but also uh
uh yeah like the second people are like
ah we're good with this um so we'll
probably finish this level um show off
the
the like labo area and then if if people
want to see a little more we can but
otherwise
i can happier just switch to uh to devil
may cry instead
look at that all right that's the game
my favorite part is it's the black it's
the black dish oh yeah
look at that i remember thinking that
meant those discs were indestructible
really that was uh it was not a good
time
dmc right dmc is on the way it's okay
you just take it easy
everything will work out i promise you
uh can i see the ps5 streaming settings
so where we actually almost
thought about doing the stream through
the stream yeah stuff itself but this
this is not through
the actual system now maybe we'll do
that
like next week or something to show it
off um
yeah hold on i have to blow into the
thing
of course of course you do you can turn
that one off by the way if
if you're somebody who for uh
uh any sort of accessibility reasons
can't can't do that you can turn that
off in this game
um that's good accessibility is an
important thing to to keep in mind
yes and the playstation 5 actually matt
talks about the review it has a very
very nice selection of accessibility
options
including like uh text uh to speech
uh chat transcribing uh like
uh you can change the ui uh font size
and stuff like that like there's a lot
of good stuff
that they've included come on
there you go can you see the menu though
there are things that we can't show
can't show the menu unfortunately um i i
if you want to see
what the menus look like you can check
that out in the review
but uh as i mentioned earlier um
we've been asked not to show it on a
live stream um just because there's a
few things that are still being ironed
out
uh what is this one
is that is that uh
[Music]
ace combat that's my guess uh
robotech on the playstation 2.
uh war the monsters
got my ps5 controller early and loving
it i kind of
feel bad i didn't order a controller
ahead of time
because i kind of would have liked to
mess around with it a little bit even
unlike my pc
right but i'll i'll get there eventually
it'll it'll have
it's next week it's a very nice
controller i
i quite enjoy it yeah it's next week
you're getting it next week then
yeah it's it'll be great well that next
generation
is gonna hit
there we go go sushima oh heck yeah
yeah i'm not gonna lie i'm it it may be
like 11am but
uh guess what game you're you're looking
at an astrobot might be a fun drinking
game
[Laughter]
find someone who who knows exactly if
you guessed wrong you have to take a
drink
of orange juice because it's early in
the morning yeah a mimosa
a mimosa the drink you can have at any
time
there we go uh what about red dead can
we talk about backwards compatible stuff
we can talk about it we can't show
backwards compatible stuff
okay so if you guys have any questions
about backwards compatible i'm happy to
answer them but unfortunately
i cannot show them do you guys know
what frame rate red dead runs at uh
if i had to yeah i i haven't measured it
because i don't have any foundry level
tools um
i feel like it's probably not 60 but
it's definitely higher than it was
no no no that game that game block has a
locked uh
30 so it won't go higher than 30. um
so if i had to guess it's probably a
pretty stable 30 which is what the xbox
series x does that game is just pretty
well optimized
and so yeah you're not going to get
above 30 um just because of the way that
game is built
um for these consoles but
it will it will be a hopefully a smooth
30
um because i think that game maybe did
drop a little bit but it was actually
pretty pretty smooth from what i
remember
uh some people asking how we're playing
the ps5 early it's because
we are news gaming outlet game spot
and we we review these things so we get
sent
stuff in advance um but
it's nice because we can kind of show
you guys
whatever we can before uh it actually
comes out
which is nice uh people also asking
if there are themes
no there are no themes okay right now
so i'm i don't know if they'll add
themes later or not but i
the way the ui is built would make
themes kind of weird
because like when you when you're on the
main menu screen
and you hover over like a game it takes
up the full screen
um so like the idea of a theme just
wouldn't really work with the way the ui
is built
outside of like maybe changing the color
um
in the settings or something but it's
pretty
yeah it just wouldn't really really work
in my opinion oh shoot apparently we'll
walk past
an infamous reference yes yes that was
an infamous reference over there
uh let's go this way i do i do love all
the people who are getting stoked for
infamous though
i've gotta believe that there's no easy
way to play uh the original two
infamouses
um outside of i guess playstation now i
don't like playstation now just because
i don't like streaming
services all that much yeah
it they they don't ever really work for
me too well
yeah i appreciate that they're there
though
um i'm not 100 sure
this one is it's a spooky game
but i'm not if anyone knows
i feel like the hat has to be part of
the
yeah that's gotta be the flashlight too
i'm not 100
if anyone in the chat can figure that
one out ah easy that's an astrobot
reference those are astrobots oh
okay easy yeah yeah yeah
um people asking uh if we've been told
what games are allowed to play yeah
they're
they're only certain things for all
multitap
or there are only certain things we're
allowed to show off
uh fatal frame silent hill
maybe maybe fatal frame the hat the
straw hat was making me like i don't
really know
that's the part that's throwing me for a
loop
because i'm like that's not really fatal
framy and it's not really silent hilly
either i'd say i would have said
tsushima but that flashlight
wouldn't block alan wake makes me think
and we already saw ghosts earlier yeah
who's demon souls they're all demon
souls
there's a good bloodborne one later on
siren might be a good call i don't
remember
siren 100 but that is a that is a
sony one isn't it yeah
uh our backwards compatible games going
to be playable
on the ps5 upgraded so how do how does
all that work
it's it's most of the library for ps4
works yeah like 99 of it works
um in our experience they've all worked
pretty flawlessly there were a couple
games that had like a couple weird bugs
resident evil 7 had a weird like
artifact-y like mosaic kind of looking
glitch
in the um in the sky at the beginning of
the game
uh which was kind of weird hopefully
that stuff gets ironed out you know by
developers
um so as far as performance goes
at on its own
they all the games basically run at the
same
uh level as like a boosted like ps4 type
performance so it like has it has like
that ps4 game boost style
thing and it runs with its own boost so
it automatically gets its own
boost just from the hardware but um
the then it comes on developers to
include
their own like patch that'll optimize it
so for example
the two games right now that we're aware
of that have patches
are um uh ghost of tsushima
and day's gone and
uh day's gone now runs at a like pretty
consistent smooth 60 frames a second
dynamic 4k it's definitely better um
having tested that out
the other one is ghost tsushima which
now runs at a smooth 60
in its um resolution mode
oh which is actually pretty wild because
so before the game had
a resolution mode and it had a frame
rate mode where the resolution would get
like bumped down to like 1080
so now you can run it on uh
resolution mode without uh compromising
the frame rate so
the framerate mode is kind of
unnecessary on that game now if you
played on the ps5 like you don't yeah
which is really fascinating um so in the
in cases of games like that
it's like wow this is a market
improvement because i can now play this
game
at the full resolution with a superior
frame rate
but but that is they did have to patch
that in so like certain games do need
patches
uh for those who want to know no
uh bloodborne does not have a patch and
it still runs
at a 30 frames with a lot of dipping
it's that game is just
yeah that game's just got a lot of stuff
on the back end that would require a lot
of work to get it
to get it going um sadly
uh yeah people in the chat we are we are
reading messages
you know we can't we can't get
everything right um
but uh for for instance
uh who was it liam liam connor and the
youtube chats asking the important
questions they want to know if fallout
76 is ever going to run better or load
quicker
you know that's one i didn't try
actually i don't i don't have it on the
playstation
that's fair i you know i would be the
weird one to say i actually enjoyed just
kind of
existing in that game not necessarily in
getting too involved in it
me too there's there's things about that
game's environment that i like
uh do you recognize this uh this
background here oh yeah
that's uh that's that that playstation 1
boot up menu isn't it
yeah it's been a long time
look at that look at that thing and they
even bring in that old
rainbow splash i love it yeah
look at that uh will you be able to play
sackboy before release
i'm sure we'll play it as soon as we can
i don't know if it's going to be before
release though
we'll play it as soon as we can um we'll
have more info on that soon
okay so then after you after you beat a
level you get sent to
the labo area uh i think that one astro
was flossing and i'm
i don't know how i feel about that oh no
oh wait are each of the levels different
playstations
okay it's coming together now has
different is is different playstations
so you'll get
uh all the stuff for them and then you
can wander around and
explore all the little uh
you pushed the button and it opened it
up
and then that's really good
this guy's just like really into this
playstation
i guess so uh i don't advise doing that
with your playstation console
but you know do you
thanks for answering your questions hey
that we're trying to try to answer as
much as we can because we're
we're not just here to show the stuff
off we're here to kind of help you guys
as much as we can
yeah so yeah this area is like super
cool it's like one of those uh
i don't know like i'm never that into
like galleries and games but because you
can actually like wander around and like
interact with all the little like
hardware that you get it's like
pretty cool also all the asterisks are
just super cute
yeah i like them i like them too they're
they're
honestly like as far as a mascot goes i
feel like that is
i'd get myself like a little astro
figurine yeah
oh we got uh how many how many gigs
is astro astrobot do you know off the
top of your head
oh i don't know
i can't imagine it's that much but
that's a good question i actually don't
know
see um
best method for getting a ps5 pre-order
without a pre-order
if i knew i'd tell you uh my outlook is
is bleak though
yeah i'm sorry man okay so then we got
this little gotcha machine we can use
all the claws
so i'm using the motion to move the hand
here
when i pull the trigger uh this is where
the with those like adaptive triggers
work really well it has like a very like
weighty like pull you have to give to
actually get it and then there's another
weighty pull when you
actually like crash it or crunch it oh
man
this is that stuff that i'm really down
with yeah this is the stuff where you're
like oh this is the potential because
this one's gold it takes even more to
like
really pull it a new artifact look at
that it's the psp microphone
[Laughter]
oh i'm so glad you crushed that that
thing to get that psp microphone
never before do you think the guy who
had to model this was like super stoked
like oh [ __ ] yeah i get it
all of my modeling career has led up to
this moment
dmc is on the way guys this is we're
gonna go to dmc right after this i think
we've
sufficiently shown off astros uh we're
just gonna keep uh
crushing some of these see what we get
uh got some people in the youtube chat
who are saying
or guessing that astros around 11 gigs
possibly i don't i don't know how true
it is but it's
i'm i'm taking it as a as a good guess
i could uh i could check real quick uh i
won't be able to show the menu but while
i'm in the menu
i could check oh there it is and there's
the camera oh it's all coming together
look at that
it is really cool to see all that stuff
again though it is
the psp was a cool little system
oh there's the ps1 ah
will ai also get upgraded in the next
gen i'm sure that ai will probably
continue to grow and be better
i hope so i that's uh something
personally i would love to see
um oh one sec so i can't pull the uh
the trigger like locks oh
which is cool i like that um
yeah no i would love to see i would love
to see more things advanced in games
outside of just
graphics yeah that is something that i
feel like
has kind of fallen at the wayside uh in
the previous gen
um i would love to see things more like
you know improve crowd tech
and ai and all that kind of stuff really
really come into play more
well all right then i think we've shown
off astros pretty well
yeah i i i'm actually really excited to
to play that i
it kind of admittedly wasn't on my radar
at all when we started this nesca like
oh cool i guess it'll be really cute or
whatever but i'm
i'm actually really jazzed to go through
and collect all these things yeah that
is
uh 100 how i felt about it i was like oh
yeah sure
i'll check this out uh i don't have much
else to play right now and then i was
like
i actually really like this a lot to the
point where i i
went and got the platinum all right guys
so
you've been asking for it we're gonna
switch over to devil may cry now
uh i hope everyone's feeling the
motivation
i'm feeling it dude i am so feeling the
motivation
you hear that that sweet new battle
theme for virgil
uh okay uh
so we're not on cool you guys can't see
anything
excellent
we're gonna put we are definitely gonna
be playing as virgil
oh yeah we're able to talk about uh
what we're able to show off like yes
we'll be able to show off missions one
through four for virgil
as well as bloody palace um we can also
show off
any other parts of the game as well if
we want to um
and yeah so we'll show off virtual we'll
maybe show off some of the the different
like graphics modes that they've added
to the game stuff like that
uh let me see if i can quickly find out
how much astros uh
takes up it is 11 gigs
oh there you go we our our our hookup in
the chat knew exactly what was up
all right oh here i hear the the jams
all right
where's scott pilgrim that's what i want
to know give me that good good beat him
up with that automatic gucci soundtrack
oh yeah when you find it let me know
uh do we know anything about psvr oh
this is straight up just the actual
opening to it
uh hold on
oh it doesn't do the capcom sound easter
egg anymore
that's that's kind of sad but i mean i'm
down because it's got virgil
so i can't be too upset um
okay so let's go to the main menu here
so
let's see what graphics options do i
currently have it set on
i set on graphics on ray tracing we'll
show that off i guess real quick
uh because that mode is cool but it's
probably my least favorite um
just because uh
i don't know like ray tracing's cool in
this game yeah it's fine
but you play this game so quickly that
it's like
you don't really notice the reflections
and lighting stuff yeah
you really don't um
like we'll we'll we'll pick this mission
here and and
show it off i guess um
this is the the good like beginning
mission yeah
so i mean first off you guys will notice
uh how
crazy fast the loading is it is like
instantaneous uh oh wow
like no more do you have to like wait to
go into the void
you have to load into that load into
this like look i'm in there you go what
hold the i was like okay i'm not going
to be too like blown away by that
because i played on pc
but that was so fast dude it's honestly
my favorite part about this special
position disgusting
it's disgustingly fast i love it i love
it
i'm going to play through devil may cry
5 again on my ps5 aren't they
it it's one of those things where like
they kept talking like yeah like fastest
d
games alone in a second like that's cool
once you see it you're like oh there's
no going back
that's a good question actually before
you jump in and fight anything
uh cr chris crazy zim i i i'm sorry if i
said your name wrong
uh is asking if you're doing legendary
dark knight mode
oh is there anything we can do we can do
it i haven't tried it yet
i don't know if i'm good enough to do
well so it's
it's it's like the same difficulty but
there's just like muso amounts of bad
guys on the screen
oh okay um it might be worth trying uh
and then go back
do you want me to go back and just and
just go for it i'm gonna be i'll be
honest
i really like legendary dark knight mode
all right let's try it let's try it
let's uh
hold on we'll go back it's okay this is
a good way to show how quick it is to
load out
yeah again we're just we're just showing
off the game here
uh also i'm really sorry that everyone
was like oh shoot we're finally in
gameplay and i'm like no wait go back i
want to see more enemies on the screen
shoot might not be able to for virgil
because
i have to play the prologue and i can't
show the prologue because it has a
special cutscene for virgil so we'll you
know what we'll show off
dark knight for um the other characters
there you go apologies about that i
didn't i didn't think about that i feel
bad
it's all right it's it's it's it's all
good we'll show virgil first and then
we'll go show
let's go show dark knight
see i it was one of my favorite modes
they added in the special edition of dmc
4
and i was like oh yeah i'm so stoked
it's back
yeah because more enemies to
beat up is always a good thing don't
mind watching that load time
yeah right it's what load time so by the
way you can
uh i think in the options
it's like you can set whether the load
time like
auto uh auto transition so like
you can actually read stuff yeah so you
can actually like you can turn it off i
think it's off by default so you'll have
to press
x i like turning it on because i'm like
no no i want to see that thing go away
as quickly as possible
for the thrill of it uh there's some
people who are
asking for for some some taunts if we
can get some
absolutely kind of like we'll try and
get some tops going yeah yeah yeah
so uh it looks like you've got your
your focus meter still which is really
cool that's an important part of playing
virgil is being cool and focused
yep i'm just i'm trying to like pick up
on a lot of stuff because i haven't i
haven't seen
the dmc 5
it's perfect
nope i got too cocky with that
so it's the first fight of the day
uh so this is with ray tracing is it 30
fps so
ray tracing is on yes this is ray
tracing on at 30 fps
it's i would say performance wise
comparable to how it felt on the ps4
um because it's fine it feels
it feels playable you know it's good uh
you could see
the the rays being traced right there
they are
definitely there these rays are are 100
being traced
um it's not it's okay
i i i don't mind it but i would say
it's not the
outside of things like cut scenes where
maybe you could appreciate that stuff a
little more
the i don't think ray tracing is
something that matters to me as much
when you're playing
a game like this because you're just so
laser focused on combat
in which case there are other options uh
you know you can do um ray tracing
uh slightly at a lower resolution uh
1080p if you still want to have a higher
frame rate or you could just turn ray
tracing off and play 4k
60. uh you could also turn off
uh ray tracing and play at a high frame
rate mode which will do above 60
if you're um sorry it's really hard to
talk and play this no it's okay
uh i was gonna say i i think for me uh
especially in action games frame rates
gonna be it
yeah i'm probably gonna be in that high
high frame rate mode all the time
so i i've been playing at um the high
frame rate mode
which which you need which you do need a
uh tv with
hdmi 2.1 to do
i'm keep i keep hearing the music and i
have to like
i feel like i have to have it oh there
you go
i just need to try not to talk over him
when he does the taunt because
i don't want to like interrupt it
uh yeah
uh ryan in the youtube chat wants to
know if anyone's tried final fantasy 7
remake on ps5 if that's gotten any
how how's that about the same or it's
about the same
the game was pretty smooth to be honest
from what i remember
um hold out the hand
he pulled out the hand um that's messed
up
let me get the uh the default one
show me your motivation oh he said the
thing
i knew you would like that he said that
you don't even have to work for that he
just gives it away for free
uh yeah uh i i found that it it went
pretty smooth i had no issues with uh
final fantasy 7 remake
rob is here hello rob it's good to see
you and he suggests turning your mic
up a bit and mine down because i i got
really stoked i was motivated the
motivation hit me too hard
let's see uh are there any are there
virgil costumes that you can wear are
there other other virtual costumes can
we talk about that is that a thing
i haven't seen any i'm actually not
aware of virtual costumes
okay so as as it stands it's
kind of just virgil in his one look as
far as i'm aware
uh i don't i don't want to confirm or
deny anything i'll just say that
as far as i'm aware i am not aware of
any costumes
but i also haven't beaten the campaign
yet as original so i don't know um
if you like unlocking yeah uh rob's also
asking for more gameplay audio because
he loves
this sweet butt rock so much the butt
rocks pretty good i can i can boost the
audio a little bit
it is it is a really big thing oh we
definitely need to get like an air taunt
see what type of cool air taunts
let's boost me a little bit
uh what tv is this being played on i am
playing this on the
lg uh the lg 20 the new
2020 lg oled uh cx
i believe it's the one that can do it's
the one that like everyone
talks about uh yeah it's got that really
nice color
it's got the hdmi 2.1 um
it's got the freesync it's got the
g-sync
it's got so many syncs it's time to be
like every sing with the kitchen sink
to be a complete lg show for a minute
it's a really good tv for gaming
i'm really happy with it
uh lucky gamer on twitch asks how long
it took you to install dmc
on the ps5 if you remember that's a good
question
what were these download times like so
we all know sony loves to have
fun download times you know that's
something i actually haven't like
properly like
tested yet but it's i will say
i feel like overall download times have
been faster than the ps4
that's good i like to hear that
yeah i'm kind of sad they kept this
stuff i don't i don't like this bit
yeah the mid-hogs the the
the pacing of virgil's campaign is a lot
faster because he's just like no cut
scenes for the most part you're
you're just cruising i'll say is
this is a part where where v is supposed
to show up isn't it
yeah there's like all this dialogue like
it's not it's it's very like classic
virtual campaign
[Music]
excuse me what was that there was a car
outside and i forgot to close my window
uh but that's taken care of i apologize
for that
oh good man gotta find another nidhogg
uh rhys wants to know what our favorite
devil may cry game
uh is uh of all of them oh
man um i think it's a tie between
three and five i think three and five
are great choices
i'm also gonna be that that
weirdo that's real you know
with the the wacky takes i really liked
dmc
oh i did too i actually really like dmc
uh it's not
i guess technically in the series but
it's a devil may cry game and i really
like the art direction in it
i kind of wish it existed it continued
to exist as its own
like thing in parallel with dmc five you
know what i mean
yeah but i really love five
and i really like three
uh actually also i'm also weird i like
four too
i like that version of dante a lot
i love forced combat yeah
pass i think five's combat is so good
see want to see the block mode is virgil
got a cool block mode
uh he does have a block uh that i
believe i unlocked
uh i should probably oh yeah no no you
answer that question
for no if you have a question
uh hi uh someone wants to know how much
longer we're going to be streaming for
uh i don't know how long have we been
streaming for i mean we just started dnc
so we'll probably play the stole for a
little bit
yeah i think we've been going for like
40 minutes
maybe i'm bad at math i don't remember
when we started i've just been having a
good time
where am i going
do they make you do this uh no that'll
make you do the same do they
oh a lot of people actually coming out
for for dmc double may cry i was really
worried that that was gonna
so i i have very vivid memories of
streaming that game the day it came out
and having i got i got put up on the the
front page of twitch when i was doing it
and i just had a bunch of people
like going after me so i'm like in the
back of my head always afraid to talk
about it
but oh it sucks it's
you know whatever but i it's good to see
the people kind of come around to it or
people just like it and talk about it
now but
i like that game
the jams every time
uh if there are cosmic virgil what
costumes would you like to see
uh i want to see him dress up like maji
magoro
there's the triple s rank
i do like the the kind of little dagger
spin i've never been
good enough to uh to trick in the middle
of
of uh combat to to
i've never been good enough for taunts
they're they're kind of like kind of
they're a risk but you know
they're fun i'd like to get to that
level oh we should we should
try to do that airtaunt too when we get
the chance i keep forgetting
so that's what he does when i do an
airtight basic
oh so they still have the uh the ability
to customize what
uh fight music plays for what character
yes
uh so if you want bury the light all the
time
okay can you do that the other question
i had is
can i finally do silver bullet as uh
an actual fight track for the whole game
oh that's a good question
because i want i want that a lot uh
silver bullet is just like the new game
plus version
of uh devil trigger and i
still listen to it every other day so
good
uh yes connor ray tracing is on we're in
the the ray tracing mode right now this
is ray tracing mode after this level
we'll switch over to
uh we'll try high frame rate mode see if
i can get that one going
um if my if my capture will let it
because i could technically i i
technically can out you might not be
able to see it but i can technically
output 1080p
at 120 here ooh
see uh some people asking about
uh if you've got any input lag when
you're running
right now like the 30fps mode not really
i find it i i don't really have any
issues with it
oh apparently there's a unique air taunt
at double s rank
oh man okay well i guess i gotta try and
do that then
i'm sorry hold on i'm not playing well
that's right we're we're asking all
sorts of questions and these guys are
they're not the most fun to find i don't
find them very fun
oh yeah do you have different weapons
too or is it still kind of really
you do you no no you do you start with
uh all three i just like yamato honestly
uh okay but i can show off a little bit
so you get um it's got beowulf
and you got beowulf
and then you got it uh i don't remember
what this one's called
oh isn't that the one that's just it's
just supposed to be like dante's
it's just dante's yeah so it's like
they're they're pretty
from what i can tell they're almost
exactly the same as dante's uh move set
so i think it's just kind of giving
virgil a little more options
uh rob's saying again uh to turn turn
you up he wants to hear your
your beautiful voice more turn me up i
already turned myself up quite a bit
in like four more decibels all right i'm
gonna move the mic closer see if that
works
i'm also just really loud and obnoxious
like really i should probably just be
brought into line and i'm quiet where he
is
so here you go look just
oh right into it boom yeah that
that was so quick mirage edge that's
what it is yes you haven't put many
points into these ones
um oh a neo angelo costume would be real
rad oh that would be really rad
um
uh will you be able to change this v or
you'll just show that
oh that yeah yeah i haven't done that
yet i can show how that works
so i should like explain probably like
the specific mechanics of his
his uh how he works in this so basically
yeah you have you have his like
concentration meter where you're like
building
up um that meter and then you can use
that concentration meter
to uh do different like
different moves that you normally
couldn't do
you could also use it so for right now i
have rank one concentration let me try
and get
rank two and then
let me hold on why am i not doing this
right
oh okay i'm sorry i'm messing up here
that's all right uh some people asking
if if we have like 3d sound on
like the surround sound 7.1 or whatever
oh
uh i think i do have it turned on
that is something you guys it only works
with headphones and
uh because of that it's not something
you guys will be able to tell like i
can't hear it right now
oh come on did you guys get a chance to
try uncharted 4
uh on the ps5 yet i've downloaded it i
haven't tried it yet i haven't i haven't
started it up yet
okay i'm playing like garbage i feel
really bad right now dig
oh okay let's i'm i'm drilling you with
these questions while you're you're
trying to concentrate it's
it's a it's a lot uh organized wants to
know if there are any more ps5 titles
we're able to play it's just these two
for now
but like we were saying before uh as
soon as we can do
oh heck yeah there he is uh as soon as
we can do anything else
you you know that we're gonna share it
with you
so let's look out like a temporary thing
then yeah so basically
you you pull him out and he'll do this
move uh but the reason you want to pull
him out
is because he'll heal you you get health
back from doing it and
the amount of health you get depends on
your concentration uh that you have
built up
so i was kind of doing that to save my
ass for my abysmal playing i'm doing
right now
ooh metal gear solid five phantom pain i
feel like someone has to have tried
mgs five and i feel like someone is
probably tam
probably uh
let's get my health back up again
that looks really cool though every time
it really does
also i'm only bumming out because i just
realized that this boss fight has a
really cool like grab
point for for for nero that you can't do
yeah i appreciate that they kept that
stuff in
from four
yeah big same
uh so v doesn't work like the devil
trigger because your devil trigger is
actually your
like his devil trigger i think is his uh
the super devil trigger
i forget what it is like technically
called that's the
the one that actually turns him into his
double trigger form see that it's that
blue meter underneath my health bar
yeah yeah um and my my three meter that
i have that my that's my doppelganger
meter
um if you hold down uh the
doppelganger button you can uh instead
of using doppelganger you can take those
meters and you can fill them into your
your
super devil trigger instead is it
actually called super dental trigger i
wouldn't feel stupid if i if
uh i don't remember what it's called we
know what we're talking about we know we
all we all understand where we're at
though
we also
all right let's see if i can get that
going uh we don't know if there are new
costumes
in the special edition
uh but yeah
is it called is it apple i don't think
it's doppelganger
the this move my sorry i can't use it
right now i don't actually the meter but
yeah it's it's doppelganger yeah
the the the super devil trigger thing no
no no no no no no no no no super devil
trigger's not doppelganger doppelganger
is a different move i can do so the the
three
purple sin devil trigger that's it sin
devil trigger there we go
i knew it was something ridiculous the
um the purple meter
i have is uh my doppelganger but i can
take my doppelganger meter and i can
convert it
into my scent devil trigger meter
oh man i just got pulled in
like i remember a name like soon devil
trigger
it is pretty metal though i gotta admit
so there you go
oh come on
where are you there he is
wow that sucked i don't even get to use
it
badass i just got all these these like
silly questions sitting on the side like
oh man can you get
like different round calls for virgil
who who calls the
the rankings for him uh right now it's
just the default one but you could
change the rankings
in the base game i assume you can still
do that on this one
yeah i'm curious who virgils are though
unless it ends up being the same person
as it is for v
because each one had a different one i
think no i think you could just set it
to be whoever you wanted
so you see uh because i had a higher
concentration i did a better version of
that
i like it
uh i'm coming in super clear but it
sounds like sean luke is
low in comparison i'll lower my i'll
raise myself more i think i just talk
quieter
just i just pump pump you up way loud
just
max it out all right all right
oh he actually cuts the screen up yep he
does
all right guys hopefully that's better i
put myself up like three more decibels
uh does adapter triggers and haptic
feedback work on this game
yes the adaptive trigger works for
nero's um revving up a great queen which
is
really cool it probably applies to the
exceed stuff yeah yeah it does it's
really rad i like it a lot
um okay so let's
go to graphics here so yeah we're on ray
tracing with high graphics mode this is
basically
keeps a little bit of ray tracing but uh
switches it to 1080 which
i don't particularly care for because i
like seeing it really nice you can have
ray tracing
off uh which i think is the best option
or you can go one step further and you
turn on
high frame rate mode let's try it
give me all those frames oh you do you
want to try
a legendary dark knight as a different
character do you want to keep going with
virgil let's do one more with virgil
uh just to show it off and then we'll
we'll uh we'll try a legendary dark
knight
with a nero i think legendary dark
knight would be a
a good like tail end thing for the
stream i think
like a whole level just packed with 30
bad guys
alright so
uh bob jones wants to know if there are
fov options in the game
oh i don't know it's been a wild time
seeing more console games getting fov
options
which i'm always down for uh richie says
you sound sound better
oh thank you cool
we've done it we've we've solved it
yeah dude the high frame rate modes
where it's at
200 percent like it's so much smoother i
don't know if you can tell
from watching but it's
it definitely looks smoother uh even on
my my preview thing
so i don't know if i can see much higher
than what discord allows but
right right it's one of those things
where it's like maybe you guys can pick
it up on the stream but really it's like
you tell it
when you're when you're playing you're
like oh the difference yeah
i i'm always a frame rate guy over
resolution
like i still haven't really made the big
jump to having like a a
monitor or anything that does like 4k
so i got the i got that refresh rate and
that's good enough for me
well so that was something that matt
kind of talked about in his playstation
5 review that i agree with is it feels
like the playstation 5 is now at a level
of power where you don't have to
compromise like
you know you can play devil may cry 5
and spider-man uh at 4k
60. you're not getting the ray tracing
but you're still like i am playing it at
a high resolution at a high frame rate
and that is awesome
uh yeah sorry sorry maybe we the the 3d
audio is
like like richie says it's it's on but
it's something that you can't really
notice through the stream no i mean
[Music]
it it's something that you can really
only appreciate um
with like headphones on like at your
house
bummer that i i had the s rank right at
the end
so i wasn't able to do the taunt
you still there ben yeah oh okay
it got quiet for a sec i was i was
trying to catch up on the chat
read what's going on no worries i can't
i can't like see anything so i'm like
oh god you're kind of just hanging out
existing like i'm just having a good
time playing as virgil
uh yeah dot williams no no 4k
stream uh there are a lot of people who
could watch a 4k stream
or i don't think we could even run a 4k
stream not at my house i mean maybe if
we were back at the office but
uh on my internet in this economy
it's less likely than you think
oh yeah the judgment cut the people are
calling for a judgment cut that's the
the they cut the screen move
oh oh oh god yeah
that's a that's a tough one to pull off
i could i could show it i could
definitely show it in the void
but um yeah at least i think that's what
it is
i i haven't played a lot of virtual
players you have to have
level two concentration you have to have
a full
sin uh devil meter to do it
it's it's i'll admit i
i'm it's tough to pull off and i'm i
don't know if i'm good enough to
consistently pull it off yet but i can
at least show it in void mode just so
people want to see how it looks
uh is the stream directly from the ps5
no we we almost did a direct ps5 stream
but
decided not to we might do one later on
though just to kind of
see how it is maybe to see how that
works
oh yeah what's the the deal with 1440p
apparently you can't you can't pick it
as an option on the ps5 or something no
you cannot
uh which was the case with the ps4 as
well um
it is kind of a bummer especially
because xbox has always let you do that
like you could do 1440p on the
the one x and you can do it on the
series x it's kind of weird that they
don't give you that as an option
um but yeah
i'm a little disappointed in that
i think that oh no go for it
i was just there's people talking about
uh yeah you guys haven't tried any ps
now games
on the ps4 no i i i i do not have a
ps now a subscription so i haven't tried
that yet
uh you got
someone just telling you to hold down
the triangle button very adamantly with
a lot of capital letters
oh
that's it that's what we're looking for
got you
i got you man
what's up what's that i'm always bad at
it
so this is when we were like ah the tech
where was it what are we doing
let's let's bring it all back together
this move i love this move
that's a fun one it's cool that you're
you're a hardcore dmc
fan but i know a lot of hardcore dmc
fans that also
know how to turn the caps lock off
you know all good it's it's not a cruise
control for cool
we can all be calm and collected here
this is this is a nice time but we got
you we appreciate
your heads up on holding down that
triangle button we got you
oh man well people hear 3d audio
and let's plays no not right now
let's say oh but with me in your b beats
by dre
headphones you know uh i i i would say
no
just because so right now it's only
supported through headphones
it's not supported through tvs which
means it isn't supported through the
hdmi
out um so right now
you would not be able to they are adding
tv support
for it um
so that will that will change
but maybe then it'll work with with
streams but i i honestly don't know i
also don't know if like
the way streams like compress audio
would like allow for that
you know what i mean yeah there's a lot
of weird stuff you gotta consider when
we're doing
streams or when you're doing like video
uploads like yeah right now we're we're
running at the 120 fps mode
uh danzay but i i think our stream is
capped at 60.
exactly like i am i'm playing the game
at 120 fps but it's not uh
you can't you can't see that because of
like you can't stream that
yeah it's there there's there's windows
i guess and stuff it's it's
it's wacky but uh
are we doing is it upscaled 1080 or
downscaled 4k this is this is
at 1080. uh actually i think
i think i'm doing this at hold on let me
let me get close to the tv
this is 1080 right now okay you you can
do it at 4k
um but my capture card literally is not
capable of that
yeah there aren't too many capture cards
that do 4k
that i can i can think of outside of
like the the elgato has like a card that
is
made for 4k um
yeah this is another good call because
we got the question
uh that was oof when you're doing the
the uh hdr stuff but are
you getting any input delay now with
more frames no definitely not getting
input delay
uh no no input delay at all it seems
cut a call to hold the playstation
button now we don't need to do that
uh omar has a question are there
specific hdmi cables that work best for
ps5 you actually did a feature about
yes hdmi cables you want to
you want an hdmi 2.1 cable if you want
to try and get
uh stuff like high frame rate mode um
you also have to have a tv that supports
hdmi 2.1
um like ben said i have a feature that
actually breaks that stuff down how that
works
uh but the hdmi cable that comes with
the playstation 5
in the box is an hdmi 2.1 cable so you
don't need to worry about
that uh just use the cable that comes
with the playstation 5.
but you do need to have a tv that can
support it obviously
oh yeah that uh richie actually linked
the uh the video right in the chat if
you want to check it out
uh richie now or later on after the
stream and get your learn on about how
to get your hdmi optimized for the next
generation of video game
consoles heck yeah um
got a question in twitch uh are you able
to stream directly from the ps5 using a
capture
device by default or like the ps4 do you
got to go into settings and toggle stuff
around like
i'm guessing like the h htcp stuff oh
like you have to turn hdc yes there is
an hdpc setting you have to turn it off
the same way
you do with the ps4 um okay
that makes sense i guess that's honestly
maybe the thing i'm the most
disappointed so far about the ps5 is
that um
even though like the the ui is nice and
new like on the back end like when you
get into the settings
it's it functions very similar to the
ps4 so it still has some of the same
weird quirks like
you know you have to manually set hdcp
instead of auto like the xbox does
you know and stuff like that so yeah
there's there's some
some things about it that i'm a little
disappointed they didn't
fix or improve based off the ps4s issues
but you know it is what it is i guess
uh i'm guessing if it works similarly
lance brings up the
using a splitter thing i'm guessing a
splitter probably works
same two oh where you would
yes so if you use this
yes but um oh
only older splitters will strip hdcp
um they don't make splitters anymore
they crack down on that with splitters
um because people are using it to like
you know take you know copyrighted
content um
so there are as far as my knowledge is
there are no
uh splitters that'll strip hdcp that do
4k
so if you wanted to do 4k capture
um you would still have to turn hdcp off
shoot i actually i'm i'm wondering about
because i've got some some older
uh splitters and all that i wonder how
this is all gonna work out for
me i will tell you i had uh
uh if you guys are talking capture shop
um i had i had to deal with a little bit
of a mess i have multiple capture cards
because of my job here and i had to
uh i normally would use the one at my
computer which
is uh only caps at 1080p but does 4k
pass through
i could not run devilmate cry5 special
edition through it because devil may cry
5 special edition
defaults to 120 fps
um and because of that my card just
straight up would not detect it which
was
a huge pain so i had to use this other
card that i have
that's like a more powerful card that
can uh detect 120 fps at 1080
and that's what i'm using right now to
stream at so if you're somebody who
streams a lot
uh be warned this game can be a little
finicky
with uh with capture cards
i wonder how how much that's gonna be a
thing like down the line too
me too um this is the only game that
i've had that problem with
uh it might be a thing where the
developers just need to like change some
settings on their end maybe they'll
maybe they'll patch it so that it
doesn't do that
uh because the game also auto turned on
hdr for me even when i turned it off at
the system level which i thought was
kind of weird um
uh is it possible we got some people
asking if it's possible to do
uh 1080 60 fps with ray tracing
in 1080 60 fps with ray tracing yes yes
you can
see there is a 1080 you go to ray
tracing performance mode
and that will do 1080 uh 60 fps with ray
tracing so if you want to experience it
that way if you're somebody who doesn't
have a 4k tv
uh and just wants to be like i want the
ray tracing i want the
the 60fps you're you're golden
heck yeah
uh also question about the create button
can can you talk about that at all or
what
what's up with that the create button um
is that the share button i'm guessing
it's probably the share button
uh i can't show it but i can't talk
about it it's really smooth it works so
fast
like you know if you're somebody i'm
sure we've all been there you try and
like take a screenshot on the ps4
and you hit the button and then it takes
like a minute
to actually take the screenshot and it's
like what the heck
uh this is like instantaneous um
it also has multiple shortcuts now so i
believe it's you
i think you hold for a screenshot and
you double tap
for a quick video it's how you do it i
think
it's one either that or it's the other
way around i'm
admittedly could be wrong but um it's
way better
it's such a smooth experience somebody
who like loved the idea of the share
button but it was like wow this is such
a pain to actually use because it's so
freaking slow uh i i much preferred it
yeah as a person who loves to over share
screenshots
uh that's just gonna make it
it's gonna make it worse for everyone it
sounds like
and that i'm just going to be sharing
things nonstop
so we're we're talking about doing uh a
legendary dark knight thing after
after this at some point some people
were asking if
uh maybe we could try the 1080 60 ray
trace thing
yeah yeah yeah if people want to if you
want to see that i mean
i guess that'll be good for the stream
uh because you guys are seeing it at
1080 anyway
uh some people calling for some beowulf
attacks in the in the stream too okay
i can give that a try i'll admit i
haven't been messing too much with
beowulf
it is kind of nice to find like the
weapon that you're you're into
you know so sometimes you just gotta
punch stuff
although i need to get up there real
quick oh my god
man now i want to play devil may cry 5
again
dude there's so many good games they're
too many good games i need
all my time is as soon as next week hits
is going to be devoted to yeah get up
there
virgil there we go oh my god you got it
it was in the bag the whole time
that was abysmal i'm very sorry about
that
it's all good ain't no thing
uh special edition's not even on pc uh
yeah that's a real bummer as a person
who played on pc
you can get virgil but you don't get
like all the other stuff yeah it is a
bummer
uh talk about ps5 on a monitor i'm sure
the ps5 works fine with monitors
whatever inputs you got yeah yeah i i've
tested it on my monitor um
and it did it does work
i i so i have a 1440p monitor and i was
able to
um play it
put plug the ps5 in and run it at um
4k it just like you know obviously it
like scales it
um but it did work just say it probably
just auto scales it to whatever the
closest thing is
some people calling for some some heavy
rain swords too
if you know how to make the the swords
come down oh
man it might be a skill that you don't
have yet too
it might be i don't remember because you
you still don't have
everything unlocked i think now whoa
oh hello uh
oh my playstation crashed
hold on everybody surprise playstation
crash
on the stream well hold on a sec i have
to
cut uh away because i can't show the ui
just gonna say
y'all seen a live a live issue here
however exclusive what you'll be nice to
know is the game didn't crash that was
the system that crashed
the game is still running oh that's
it's almost like it did it on purpose to
show off like a feature like oh
your console done your game isn't also i
was literally one way hit away from
killing her which is why i was confused
because the game like paused for a
second i was like did i kill her
i'm that doesn't seem right
guys that's why the the the
speed of of loading and the fact that
your console crashed you came back and
picked up in less than like 15 seconds
is a lot for me to handle yeah
weird that's that's a lot that's so good
though
i've i have had that happen a few times
um
it's weird because it's not the game
crashing it's like the system crashed
it's like it's weird it's really weird
yeah i'm hoping that stuff kind of gets
ironed out
because i'm not really sure what's
causing that um anyway
let us try uh
not okay that's not what i want
let's get that the 1080 60 okay yeah you
guys want to retracing
yeah on performance um
oh sorry guys so
apparently as we see in the settings
there ray tracing is automatically
disabled in legendary dark knight and
turbo mode
uh i guess we know we can turn it on but
i guess we're going to legendary dark
knight so we just take it
yeah um i guess we'll just go to go to
4k 60 then um it's interesting that it
that it disables that
it's probably because it can't reflect
all like 50 of the
enemies that are on the screen on the
water
i guess so
uh okay yeah let's uh
oh did you start up the prologue or you
just don't show it with anyone no
no no no i just can't show it for for um
for virgil
gotcha oh you still got the andrew wk uh
skin for nero that's great
uh some more questions about when you
plugged into your 1440p monitor like
what were the
the options for you to display it at uh
it only gave me
um 720p 1080p
uh 1080i was disabled and then uh 4k
so do not give me so it's a case where
my monitor is just like
lets me scale it i don't know if that's
a
my monitor is like good about that or
something
or if that's a ps5 specific thing but
yeah like i was able to play it on the
monitor it's a 1440p monitor
and it just it the system was running at
4k but it just like downscaled it to my
monitor all right now i gotta remember
how to play nero after
a year this is uh this is legendary dark
knight mode though so we got
i don't see the initial change here
it is the prologue we'll see i guess
yeah
i did pick it right i'm not crazy like
you saw that hold on
press start again really quick i i
didn't i trust you
it says just uh human
says human i don't think we picked it oh
did we not pick it hold on maybe i
didn't pick it
let's go back we got too excited maybe
we got too excited
it's okay the loading is non-existent oh
i did pick human that's
yeah that's why i'm like nailed this
doesn't seem right
there we go we got you we got you guys
it's all good
dante dante
okay but you know this game
it looks it looks really good yeah all
right this game looks great
all right let's just skip that come on
don't care about
oh yeah there we go yeah yeah that's
that's that's right
that the math is here it's all good okay
so i have like no combos
that's okay you'll get him as you go
you'll you'll get all your moves
uh three times as fast because there are
three times more enemies
that's a you know what that's a good
point i didn't think about it that way
all these these red orbs they're just
everywhere
oh wow yeah look at my look at my orb
count
oh yeah i'm dude i'm feeling that
adaptive trigger
does it like when you you get higher
levels does it have more resistance
that's a good question i haven't oh you
don't have other levels unlocked yet
though
oh god yeah i don't just
i got excited and got ahead of myself
again yeah i can't do
any of my combos this is excellent
yeah crashes aren't that big of a thing
like there's never going to be
a piece of hardware that never crashes
that's right
to be honest i'm just like impressed
that like it can crash and then the game
still
runs yeah granted that is a it was a
system crash not a game crash
i have had a actual game crash and that
is the case where yeah like the game
just straight up crashes
but again with fast loading it's like
you're back in the game
really quick
and how long have we been going for
we've been going for
uh when we start at 10 30
yeah uh an hour and a half it's it's oh
noon okay well we'll probably want to
call it fairly soon i mean i i will try
and show off a little more dark night
mode here
all right oh my god legendary dark
knight the last thing we do and
we'll uh we'll leave everyone off to
their their wonderful fridays
i need i need to get combos
dude it's just you know just a little
bit of why
a little bit i don't have your arms yet
i don't recommend playing this with uh
with a fresh save
you got you got it this is unlocked this
is totally fine
a okay
i just i love that this mode is back
look at all these look at all they just
keep coming out
there's so many of them
it's 2 am here oh man i'm glad that
that you guys are are hanging out
all over the world even when it's it's 2
a.m
oh ben this isn't gonna work yeah you
know
that's fine it's we should it's a mode
that exists we saw how many more enemies
there are
you can keep going if you want i'll uh
i'll give it one more try here but
yeah yeah i guess going in here with uh
a base level character is
is kind of a lot maybe maybe not the
ideal way to play this
i mean i appreciate that they give you
the option to play it up front like
that's cool but oh boy
oh boy maybe don't maybe maybe at least
get a little bit of uh
a little bit of abilities first
crazy
yeah i'm just sitting here thinking like
oh man what if like this was post gaming
you were able to like grab
them grab and actually do like any sort
of like air combos or something
okay yeah so we could do maybe a bloody
palace run or something with uh
with virgil sure yeah why not why not
let's do that
and then whenever whenever the bloody
palace ends that's when we'll
break it off sounds good to me man
yeah yeah yeah okay
um remind me where the heck bloody
palace is
in this game secret missions
is that under secret missions or mission
no it's not mission select
no i'm like completely spacing out where
bloody palace is oh do you need to beat
the game to unlock bloody palace
maybe can anyone remember if you have to
beat the game because you have to beat
the game
then it came out uh posts
it did come out post isn't that true
yeah
you go into the void and mess around a
bit i guess
sure why don't i why don't i show
judgment cut
let's get these these cool moves
can i
fired ass
i might actually play some double macro
5 later on today
if i remember to i know
oh yeah try to get that double s uh air
taunt if you can
sure die
yeah yeah yeah
fly
is it this that is the
little air tom doing huh
is it is that not the right one i assume
that's not what people are looking for
yeah maybe maybe he doesn't have an air
taunt
man but nero does that really cool like
he grabs his feet
and does like a cool skateboard trick
die that might be my favorite uh line
besides his uh
his motivated taunt from base level
let's see if i can get a yeah i'm
guessing
that you don't have a lot of the beowulf
stuff unlocked so someone's asking for
seeing one of the specific combos that
you unlock in the shop but
oh yeah i don't have that unfortunately
sorry sorry devil
don't we don't have the the beowulf
stuff
yet it's possible that uh
the air talk could be a secret taunt
that i haven't unlocked yet oh that
could be it uh yes this is
ps5 gameplay
where we're on a playstation 5 live
before your very eyes stardom
if you just joined in and was expecting
me to be pulling off sick combos in the
void you
don't expect that i'm not that kind of
uh double my crime player
uh what resolution are we playing it so
this is this is the 4k
this is the 4k 60 no ray tracing
yo but what would ray tracing look like
in the void though
that's a good question i'd riddle me
this
show me the ray tracing in the void
try to talk with no s rank and you'll do
a taunt that launches the enemy
it's a combo
okay so i do i do this
when i when i maybe with like a lower
string yeah yeah yeah i do that like
that
that's good try try it with the
single ass i just do the same thing it's
the okay
see like a cool cool combo dealie yeah
it just keeps the combo going basically
well all right um i mean
i think that's about it can i maybe i
can get my like
meter all the way up
here what if i
maybe i could i can lock my unlimited
devil trigger
at max and i can do uh
show me that that uh sin devil trigger
if you can
oh some double trigger yeah sure yeah
let's just see what he he looks like i
wanna
look at him
oh come on
don't move
that's what we wanted heck yeah there
you go i'm happy that we could we could
help you guys
okay so that's that's his his double
trigger
yeah that's the synth devil trigger um
and then
if i can i think it's
wait am i doing it right hold on
me yep here it is
yeah that's the thing i was thinking of
that's what you guys wanted to see so
yeah that is you you have to have full
sin devil trigger and concentration
level two to pull it off
but uh yeah there you go you shall die
see it again
yeah that's that's good
i think that's a good way to end it we
showed off the game hopefully you guys
had a good time seeing the game
um i i'm excited to watch some like
actual good devil may cry players do
some crazy [ __ ] with
with uh virgil once this game comes out
big save
your don geary and uh all those guys
pulling off those sick moves well thanks
for watching everybody
hopefully you had a good time and uh go
check out all of our playstation
coverage
over on youtube.com gamespot uh
we all been working real real hard a lot
of
a lot of late nights to get to get these
videos out for you guys so hopefully you
all
enjoy them and i mean i think we're
going to be doing a lot more
coverage with streams and other stuff
next week as well
for both the playstation and the xbox so
look forward to that yeah and uh if you
did like what you saw today you should
definitely subscribe to the channel or
follow so you don't miss a single thing
we do we we
stream sometimes we're trying to get
back to streaming normally
i think maybe don't miss a single video
we do
you can stick around and hopefully we'll
see you again
because it was nice it was nice doing a
stream i felt felt like it's been a long
time and i missed doing it
yep all right see you guys bye everybody
yes